The general gun experience. Look,
fucking Trump just pass something and no one wants to give him credit for this.
He stuff was the kidney stone. He did.
He did wonderful stuff for kidney transplant stuff. I'm sure he pushed through.
Well that was going to say that he absorbed all the student loans for disabled
veterans. Fantastic. I love it.
You don't hear a word about it and where to praise. Look,
we should absolve student loans for fucking everyone. We're crippling kids.
We're crippling the 1718 year old kids who sign up for these fucking loans and
they get compromised to the point where we have people to this day right now
that are getting their social security money,
their social security money's getting docked because they owe student loans.
They're at the end of the fucking road. What do you do? What do you do? Uh,
and this is a real question. This is not rhetorical.
What do you do about the feeling of fairness?
The people that work their way through college waiting tables?
That's a good question. Working really hard. And then they, uh,
do we just say their feelings, which I think is valid, which is,
yeah, yeah, you got fucked on this, but let's help someone else out.
What are we here? Compassion. Here's the goods. You know, um, uh,
there are people that worked really hard to not have student loans and there are
people that took them. Um,
there has to be somebody who took them prevalently 100%. I think quite a few.
And I think it's also,
we also should pay attention to the human mind and the development of the human
mind and the frontal cortex.
And the frontal lobe does not develop properly until you're 25 years old. Right?
Right. So some, somewhere in that restaurant minus four years,
definitely out 17, it's definitely not 18 months.
So you're taking on these fucking loans. You, you, you,
you can't be trusted with money or your future or thinking about what the fuck
you're doing in terms of like taking on a debt of hundreds of thousands of
dollars doing this also ties in, um, uh, with,
with bisexual stuff as well.
Don't we have to decide when someone's adult and then give them that respect.
Yes. We have to say you're 18 years old.
We can't control what decisions you make. Yes.
And one is that you're going to be, cause I think 25 is too old.
I think 25 is too old as well. But I think what we're saying is, I mean look,
there's a lot of 18 year old people that make very good moral decisions. Yes.
And we should, we should praise that.
Here's the problem with the student loan thing. In terms of the fee,
that's the only loans that you never get exonerated from.
You can get bankruptcy, right? And you can get exonerated. You can,
you could escape the loans of credit cards,
the debt of mortgages.
You could escape a bad business collapsing and owing millions and whatever you
get. You could escape that through bankruptcy.
You cannot do that with student loans. It's a corrupt system.
You take a child who's trying to learn a trade or trying to learn a profession
and you acquire insane debt that's going to track you and cripple you for the
rest of your life and no matter what happens to you, you owe that money.
But also you're taking your colleges out of the free market too by giving those,
by giving those loans easily. Yes. And by having government help, yes.
You're also, you're also taking away the free market because you know,
we found out that when you put the free market in like LASIK surgery,
when insurance doesn't cover it, it gets wicked cheap. You know?
And if colleges had to be paid as people went without easy loans to get,
and if colleges did not get government money, they might be wicked cheaper.
I think they would be really, really expensive.
I think the expense is crazy expensive.
I think the real solution is in treating education like a thing that's going to
make our society better.
And think of it as the same way we think about the fire department.
Same way you think about,
please don't you think that, I mean when you read the paper,
there's always one whole thing about colleges getting too expensive and people
can't go.
Did they keep that and then you turn 20 pages later in the paper and there's an
article about how online learning is going to happen is happening and all this
stuff is going to happen.
Do you think that that idea of college is going to hold up for another 10 years?
I think there's an experience that people, I mean, did you go to college?
Well I did, but I went to college in my town. I went to UMass Boston and uh,
I really only went because I didn't want to be a loser.
It was really all it was. I was, uh,
doing martial arts and fighting and traveling all over the world or all over the
country rather. And, and thinking about doing standup at the time as well.
And then transitioning to doing standup while I was also still taking classes,
I was learning nothing. It was a complete waste of time.
I was only doing it so I could say, yeah,
taking classes at UMass Boston and I was barely paying attention,
barely showing up. And um,
it was just a thing that I didn't want to tell people that I wasn't going to
college. Like that was the number one reason why I did it, but I, but that was,
I had a unique life from the time I was, uh, you know,
graduating from high school to the time I started doing standup.
I was obsessed with martial arts and competing and that's all I wanted to do is
make the Olympic team for TaeKwonDo. That's what,
that was my goal and that's what I was trying to do.
So I wasn't a normal person.
I wasn't like I wasn't going to go to Ohio and fucking travel over there and
take a full course load and not be able to pursue what I wanted,
what I wanted to do.
Oh, so you've got a window. I think politically it's fairly small.
No, there was no scholarships for TaeKwonDo, doesn't, it didn't exist.
And the only other option was the army. There was a dude,
I think his name was clay, Barbara's,
this really talented guy was a fighter who was, uh, on the U S team,
had one point in time I think. And he was a competing through the army.
Like they, they had subsidized his training somehow or another.
And I was thinking maybe I should join the army, like those, the other,
the only other thing that I was thinking about doing, but um, for people,
I think there's a thing about getting away from your parents,
getting away from them, getting away from their influence,
being wild and crazy and be with a bunch of other kids and trying to find
yourself. And I think that comes from traveling to a place and going to college.
And I think there's, there's some benefit in that.
And I have friends that have had great benefit in that sort of a transformative
experience of being on a campus,
a physical campus in a place that's outside of their hometown where it gives
them this new experience where they get to try to reinvent them.
So they're still got a book that people do that being able to be someone else.
But I wonder, I wonder if all of that,
why are we giving that a four year period? Why isn't that our whole lives?
It can know. It could be and should be.
And isn't that the way that's going to change?
Because people aren't having jobs for their whole life anymore. And by the way,
the liberal arts education was never supposed to teach people a trade, right?
It was always supposed to make it so that young men could talk in parties.
We could have the same cultural thing. We can tell about Shakespeare.
We can talk about this, we can talk about that.
But none of this was meant to give people jobs. Well, it's so rigid, right?
You get out of high school,
high school was this torturous affair where you're being a square peg,
they're trying to shove into a round hole.
Then you get out and then they fly off to wherever the fuck you're going to go
to school and you go there and you're forced with this overbearing workload of
school and then social things.
You're trying to figure out what's okay and what's not okay now where's the safe
space and well am I, what am I?
Am I allowed to say this and am I allowed to say that?
And what are the new rules now for this new generation or are we really gonna
change the world?
And then all of a sudden you're out in the world and you realize that fucking
money that you spent or that loan that you got is not getting you a job and
you're fucked and you can't get a job and you're also massively in debt and
severely depressed and trying to figure out your future. I mean,
Mindy go on Adderall and then you're like,
we're setting people up. We're setting people up for a horrible failure.
I am with Bernie Sanders in that I think education should be free and I don't
think that's a bad thing. I think you should earn it.
I think you should have to earn it.
How bout if education is really cheap?
Like everything else is getting cheaper? Well, I mean, TVs are really cheap,
more expensive.
I think we can pay for it with taxes maybe wrong or the individuals could pay
for it. Maybe the individual is cheap and if it made sense, if it made sense.
I mean, if you want to learn something now we know this very well.
If you want to learn anything now you can get it for free on the web.
You definitely can't do many things. I mean, other than physical things,
there's a lot of physical things that you need to be taught by a coach.
I think there's a lot of things you can learn online and even the physical
things, you can get a big chunk of it from online tutorials. I mean let's,
let's talk about all that matters. Okay. Let's talk about juggling. You know,
I grew up as a juggler when you were doing the TaeKwonDo,
I was juggling all the time.
That's all I did and that was my whole life was juggling.
And what happened was with the internet juggling gut
tremendously better because people could watch videos of things they knew were
possible and get better. If juggling get better.
Physics certainly can.
It seems like you can take a course at any college online and if you sincerely
want to learn, you know, I don't know if we need to have this, what is,
what is the term called when the,
when the Amish take their one year of Rumpelstiltskin assessment.
I'm spraying Rumspringa, I'm spraying,
I don't think we need a nationally tax subsidized rum spring for every person in
the country. I don't think that it is. Right. Yeah. You go to college,
well you just described you do the dah, dah, dah, dah, dah.
It seems like live your fucking life.
There isn't this four year magic period or there's two year magic period and go
out and learn the stuff you want to learn. I mean, um, you know,
we both have children and they'll be talking about going to college and of
course my, my not of course,
but my wife will push very hard for college and my thinking is anything they
want to learn, they can, they can just learn it. You know, by the way,
this was also true with just the libraries in local towns.
It's just more true now. It's even easier now. You know,
I can't imagine growing up where my,
my son can type in Lenny Bruce and it all just pops up. Right? I mean,
that was amazing. Store order it, order it.
They didn't grip into Gribbins music store in Greenfield,
Massachusetts did not have the Carnegie hall concert right there in the stacks.
I had an order, Oh, Frank Zappa,
I'm back a one of his records mentions Lenny Bruce and he's on Sergeant pepper.
I guess I should learn about him. Um, uh, let me write that down.
That's how I learned about Terence McKenna.
I learned about Terence McKenna from listening to a bill Hicks record. Yeah,
yeah. I was like, who's this McKenna and what's a heroic dose? And at,
at Frank Zappa, one of his records, I forget what year it is,
I think it's freak out, but it might be absolutely free. Says on the back.
Do not listen to this song until you've read Franz Kafka in the penal colony.
Ah, I got the record, opened it up. It said that I listened to one side,
got to that song, got on my bike, rode down to the Greenfield public library.
Kafka. I've got this written down. Kafka in the penal colony. Sat there,
Reddit went back, listen to the record.
My entire education starts with Mike Nesmith of the monkeys who said,
listen to Zappa.
Listen to Hendrix from Zappa to Lenny Bruce from Lindy Bruce to the whole world.
And I believe that, uh,
that is available to everybody all the time. I mean, I don't know,
as I would say tax players should pay for college. I think I would say,
do we need college? Isn't that fade in a way?
I think there's a real benefit to being in a classroom with a brilliant
professor. Yeah. Yeah. I think there is, but we're also seeing with Ted talks,
which I know are jive, but there is a, there's always, you know,
their job, there can be a lot of jive Ted talks. There's some jive Ted talks.
Yeah. Yeah.
But what I'm saying is I went to one of the first Ted conferences and
[inaudible] and got to hear, um, you know, um,
all these credible people speaking.
It was mind blowing and I wasn't college age. I was, you know,
I was whatever I was 45 or something 40 and it was,
it was an amazing spirit. Jonas Salk, you know,
I sat and listened to Jonas salt talk.
I been in a room with brilliant people speaking and it's really,
really great. But I think we can,
we can deliver that cheaper. And that's the side that Bernie Sanders,
I want to talk about. It's not,
can we give endless amounts of money to these fucking people on college
campuses?
Can we pay them all the money in the world to take our children and give them
something to do in between smoking dope? Could we rather just say,
can't we make this experience cheap enough so that anybody can go and experience
it? Why don't you, why?
Why isn't it possible for you for a few bucks to go and be in a room with a
brilliant person?
I think that would be a thing that would be beneficial to almost anybody at any
point in time instead of the rigid structure of like, you know, this is you.
You know, you have to get all this work done by X amount of time.
That's the other thing that happens to kids too.
They're taught about having no sleep and about beating your body up and about
cramming and about getting all this work done in a short period of time.
They're really,
we're really preparing them for a horrible job and all this shit that doesn't
work. You know, all that weird,
that weird kind of hazing shit that we do for medical professionals.
You're going to work for fucking never weren't saying it's terrible for the
patient. It's were bad for everybody, you know?
So my wife and you just made the argument about the frontal cortex and you're
not really ready to,
you're 25 and what are the huge advantages I had in my life was a shitty,
shitty education, horrible education. You know, I went to a bad, bad,
bad public school that had an influx of hippies from UMass that came in and
experimented on us. So we had no education whatsoever.
I graduated from high school and a plea bargain.
I had very good, um,
S a T so I had scholarships to wherever I wanted to go,
but I chose not to because I misunderstood Bob Dylan.
I didn't know he was lying.
So I went and hopped trains and hitchhiked around and lived homeless for a
couple of years and I never read Moby Dick till I was 45. Thank you.
If I'd read Moby Dick when I was supposed to, would call the judge,
I wouldn't have gotten it.
But I was able to get it at the right age and now it's my favorite book cause I
was ready for it. You know,
there's so many things that are on the curriculum that are very, very important.
Maybe not that day.
I think there's also an issue with people not thinking of education in terms of
like that it's a lifetime for sure. Yeah.
It's not something that you graduated from college and then you're done.
We really should be educating ourselves throughout life and not just
accidentally or incidentally by experiences.
We should do it because there's things that we pursue that are interesting. Yes.
Now is one of the greatest times ever to do that because of audio books.
You can do it while you're in the car.
You could do it while you're on the train.
You can get educated and you can also,
they're doing this weird connecting thing where I've not experimented with this,
but I'd love to where people take courses online and then find people who are
also taking courses online in their communities and then meet it like a fucking
Starbucks to discuss what happened before, uh, in the class,
which is mind blowing that that can happen. So you can take, you know, uh,
one of my huge,
I mean one of the things I wanted to do was I wanted to learn to play jazz on
me, play upright bass.
I took that up at 45 and I learned to play upright bebop base.
Passably a huge accomplishment. And now I really want to learn a language,
you know, so I was looking at a little bit,
cause I figured maybe there's a government watch list I'm not on,
so I should learn Arabic
cause don't you think that that takes all the boxes that's going to give me
everything if I just learn Arabic.
So I started looking into how I can learn how I can learn, uh,
Arabic and uh,
it's amazing the kind of network that's developing all over the world to be able
to learn anything. So my argument with you, uh, on the, on the, uh,
on the Bernie thing of paying for everybody's college is I think we can get
college so fucking cheap. You can go to college your whole life. Well,
I don't think that's a bad idea. You know,
if it's possible to get college that cheap,
but I don't want professors to be poor. I mean,
I think one of the real problems we have a Pudge with public education is that
people don't want to be a teacher because Patriot teachers don't get paid much.
Sure. But there's a, there's a way, there's,
I would say that's government intervention that's doing that.
I would say if you government intervention is keeping the salary low.
I think so. Really?
I really think so because I think that we're not having enough of the of the of
the of the competition is stuff. I mean, um, you know, you,
you would pay good money to be in a room with the Steven Pinker, you know,
and I think that locally, this was always a problem that I never figured out.
You know, when I was in Greenfield, Massachusetts, a town of 20,000,
I would say to all the other, uh, by other high school students, I would say,
you know,
if we didn't give her money to the rolling stones and the Beatles and Dylan and
all these other bands,
we could pull our buddy together and have a really good local band.
We could have a great band
right here in town. You know,
and I think that if you thought of education that way,
can't we get in our little area really great teachers, you can teach this stuff.
It might be pretty boss. Well,
it'd be amazing if we could spread education right through any, any method,
whatever we can do, if we can encourage people to be more educated.
But I think that one of the best ways to do it really is just, look,
there's a lot of podcasts that are educating people.
There's a lot of information that you can get and it's minor, but it's,
what we're getting is there's more information available now than ever before.
I think it's very different than what colleges traditionally is a thing where
you go and it's a Rite of passage. It's like,
and we don't have those in this world. And I think we could do with them.
I think we could do with these rights, particularly for young men. I don't mean,
and maybe it's the case for young women, obviously I never was one,
but when you're a young man,
there's this transitionary period where you're a boy and then all of a sudden,
am I a man yet? Like when am I a man? Certainly a lot of, a lot of cultures,
religions has done that.
Getting thrown into getting that certificate and getting your diploma.
Holy shit, I graduated from fucking university. I'm a man now.
I am a grown up. I have a degree. I am a woman now. I have a degree.
I am an adult. And you're obviously, you know, uh, I'm, I'm seeing this,
you know, it's okay to speak with an accent. It's not okay to hear with one. Uh,
I'm hearing that from someone who spent an awful lot of time explaining to
myself and others why I didn't go to college. You know,
you wanted to show you weren't a loser. I didn't have that.
I didn't say I went to Ringling brothers Barnum Bailey greatest showrunner of
clown college. You know what I mean? If you want a big shore,
you don't get respect. That's where you go. Well, I'd say I talk about,
it's just cause I want people to really know where my head was at.
I don't want to like glorify college.
I went without any Rite of passage at all. Right. You know,
and the closest I had to a right of passage was earning my living. Well,
the true shoot. You were also, you were on a different pursuit.
Like your pursuit was the Carney pursuit and you enjoyed that. I mean,
there was like a, you have how to lust for it, you know,
it obviously worked out well.